all right janine
janine where'd you grow up where are you
from originally i'm from los angeles
california i was born in february in
1969. i'm an only child
raised by her father
or his mom my mother was a upward bound
black female in the 70s
right
women's live and all that good stuff
right and she chose career
and my father raised me
how would you describe your childhood
wonderful
i loved growing up in los angeles i went
i've lived from here to the east coast
right and everywhere i've been i
wouldn't have wanted to be raised
anywhere but here
right and i've enjoyed all of the places
that i've lived but los angeles to be
raised here
it was a whirlwind tour and i and i was
a teenager during the 80s so it really
was a whirlwind tour what uh what
neighborhood were you i grew up in
inglewood in the avenues so what uh i'm
not getting affiliated so i don't know
anything about what neighbor all that i
don't yeah so what was what was so great
about l.a
it was
just
it was just l.a
i can't describe it anyway other than
that if you've never been here before
please come
and then you'll understand what i'm
saying
but there's just nowhere other than here
like here
across this whole country you know what
i'm saying
yeah and it was it was just
the exposure to so many different things
was wonderful you know as far as being
to
acclimate myself to other people
to you do you understand
i don't have i used to have biases i'm
very acidity i'm very uppity i'm very
all of those things first and foremost
because i was unaware
right that uh
ebony and ivory
live together and perfect harmony side
by side on the count on the piano
keyboard it's real [ __ ] right
but you have to be aware and be exposed
and not be limited and held back to
understand that it is just we're just
really people
right going through whatever it is that
our journeys dictate that we go through
right it's not for you mine is not for
you yours is not for him
right
and so that's the thing that i came to
being on the streets from where i where
i
came from
you understand what i'm saying it's like
i was
i became
not exposed but
aware
right because i'm when i said i went to
all-girl high school
you understand
and so
yeah i used to think that
oh my god what really oh
as i walk down the street by people
you understand what i'm saying today
i walk down the street how y'all doing
you know
really
it's not it's i understand that man is
just man
right and of course yeah i'm racial
why wouldn't i be
right
race racial as a [ __ ] for real
right talking about you like a dirty job
you have your back
what would you say is the most
significant thing that happened in your
in your youth
the most significant thing that happened
in my youth
was
leaving my mother
going to my father no but after that
after that
um
what was the most
but drugs okay let me explain
my family had a liquor store
in our in our structure right
so
getting being out of the
rational mind
i've always been around party
since i was a little girl glamour
you understand i've always
uh yearned to be more than i was and i
was a whole bunch
i just didn't realize it as a kid
because that's where i came from that
was my norm
right but as i started to develop and
come across other people's lifestyles
then i
i was aware that there was more to be
had and i yearned for it and so i
acclimated myself to all the fast-paced
people that were around me right and it
was the glamour of it all
really the very first time i took a hit
off of a goddamn pipe i was madly in
love and it overwhelmed me i remember
the day when the party turned into the
lifestyle
right how old were you
probably about 20 i didn't have any kids
so i probably was anywhere between 22
and 26.
i don't remember dates
that well because i've compar
compartmentalized if i'm saying it right
my whole life
right i put things in the bottom drawers
that are easily accessible and things
that are hurtful i put on the top drawer
right where i can't get to them that
quick
you get it and so um
i don't remember all the details and
dates and [ __ ] like that somewhere
around the early 20s
that's what i said all of that to say i
smoked a little reefer earlier and so
yeah my
is off as far as bringing things up to
my and where where's your life going
since since then since the early 20s i'm
sorry where did your life go after after
you smoked for the first time
where was where did i say again to your
question where it was it didn't go
anywhere i didn't have to go through
strife and struggle
i worked i came from a family that was a
very close-knit family very loving
family i'm the black sheep
right and i'm black sheep by choice not
because i was sacrificed to be
do you understand i came from a family
full of women
so i and i am very aware and i pay close
attention and so even though i might
have gone the other way
and i was told that that way was the
dead end
you understand i still went that way
because
it was my choice
right i didn't i was i hid for myself i
played peekaboo with myself for a long
time
right because of where i come from
the example that was set forth for me
to follow you know the um
and
yeah it took a long time for me to be
able to
be like okay you can breathe
ginger oh
and so yeah but today more than back
the the procession that i've gone
through has been
at 20 my bottom line was this 30 it was
that 40 it was that 54.
it's just so mild mannered and cool and
accepting because guess what it hasn't
changed it's come along with me the
whole goddamn way right and so i have to
make it encompassing for everything that
i do acknowledging and realizing that
that monster is chasing me the whole
time my guy told me the other day he
said [ __ ] you fighting the battle that
you just don't want to
say that you're gonna lose
so you keep fighting it when you could
just a lady out and say god damn i bet
you would
you understand
but one day i'll come to that point
and you know but what day that is it
could be the day after i die i don't
know
you're living on skid row now no not at
all i've never lived down the street by
a day of my life you just come down here
to party no yeah i just came down here
because these are my folks
we'll talk
right i'm beautiful and i'm this and i'm
deaf down here
whereas when i'm at home i might be a
pitiful little uh you know what i'm
saying
that's why i'm down here are you working
on the street
yeah you ever figure out no i don't know
where you were wherever my feet are
are you serious
i'm not relegated to one particular area
i was in the program like i was like 20
okay i had been i had
so i probably was like 30.
and i'm just realizing that
at 30 i'm finally an adult during my 20s
i was just an extended teenager i still
had the beliefs in all that that i had
as a teenager they were just more
advanced and developed at 30 i had
become
able to know that i'm supposed to think
even though i may not have thought
about different things going on in my
life you know
and
so my bottom line changed from 20 to 30.
right from 30 to 40 it changed when i
turned 40 i was in prison
right
and so from 30 to 40 it changed
at 50
either i hold on to myself and i hug
myself and i love me the little bit that
i know how to love of myself
or i'll be one of those [ __ ]
and i don't mean it to be
harsh when i say those [ __ ] i
mean it to because those [ __ ]
along the way have not realized that
they gotta get back
and they don't have to not have on shoes
and they don't have tonight and they
don't have tonight and they don't have
to not
but that's just coming from my
perspective
right because their perspective is
totally different than mine
right
you have kids
three
you raised them nope
i um
they were with me at the beginning
right i told you the very first oh
yeah you don't need to get into the
details yeah i can't because i can't
understand not on film not for the rest
of my
eternity
yeah what was it what was the happiest
time in your life
okay so the happiest time of my life
would have to be
right now
because i'm living i'm breathing i've
circle i've surpassed
different marks in my own thinking that
we're going to be my demise
right um
yeah right now today is the happiest
time of my life
what was the roughest time of your life
the day that i uh watched myself cross
over from
party to lifestyle
the day that i realized that
actually you want to know really what
the hardest day of my life was i'll have
to say
when i turned 50
53
when i turned 53
everything started rushing on my
shoulders
like you silly ass [ __ ]
you wasted
unnecessarily
do you understand
and how dare you
right
it was that day
you know i get upset with myself
because i
am accountable to me now
i used to did not be accountable to me
because it was all just like
it's just
breathing and exhaling
you know what i'm saying not really
understanding because i'm so selfish as
an only child i'm so self-centered i
thought you grew up in a family of women
i did i'm an only child though
my father is the only boy out of five
sisters
i'm his only child i see okay
who he raised
right
so i was always with my grandmother
right and our family is so close then my
one of my aunts now has
eight daughters
the largest girls and so
for my
youngest aunt
to my oldest cousin there's a two-year
difference and after my youngest i mean
my oldest cousin we all fall
stair-stepped
with only three grandsons you think
there's a chance that you'll never put
down the pipe there may be because today
i buried friends of mine
that i couldn't it was unimaginable that
they had even
they would ever pass
i mean you know what i'm saying
my comrades in the trenches
right
my family
you understand
and
so now life is very very
fragile to me at 54. it's not invincible
to me anymore
right i'm not invincible anymore i used
to think that i was invincible my knees
hurt
right my gray hair is so coarse that
drives me crazy because it pricks me in
my scalp
i refuse to die because i want to be
elegant and gracious as i grow you still
are right and i think that right i've
been blessed
with i remember hearing my uncle tell my
aunt one time he's like damn you thomas
women grow you guys get better with age
and as i've grown older physically i'm
just speaking
i've gotten better physically right i
think that my
the mature janine is way more
appealing and attractive than my younger
geneve
i was very insecure and even though i
was confident in my approach in my
presentation
i was very [ __ ] insecure and
bewildered and all that as you know
growing up because i was by myself as in
my house as an only girl when my dad
went to work
i was coming home
from high school he went to work
at 3 15. i came home at 2 45. that's it
you understand people
when he was coming home from work at 11
30
i was going to bed because i had to be
to school at 8 45. you get it
i raised myself but i didn't
i had influence that was
very um
influential
right
very very
i know right from wrong i apologize for
going the wrong way
right
but
that's my journey
you've been loved before i'm sorry have
you been in love before
with myself
no i'm just teaching
i thought i was every time i thought i
was in love
i really realized after the relationship
was over that love isn't what i thought
that love was
now this is the thing
i
several men that i have been with tell
me all they have told me i shouldn't say
tell me all the time but they've told me
that i don't know how to love i don't
like men
imagine that i love the [ __ ] out of
black men
especially
right and there is a difference
i've never dated a white boy in my life
my daddy told me when i was a little
girl never bring one home
right and i've never brought one home
right my mother told me that's all i
better get
imagine that
okay do you guys get it
i'm all confused
anyway
what have you learned about men
in your line of work you learn a lot of
interesting things right yeah yeah know
it whatev what have i learned about men
is this same thing that i've learned
about everybody else take them on face
value take them from what they approach
what they present themselves with their
actions their words always are
in uh
battle with each other right
and just accept them and be gracious at
all times because your [ __ ] life
depends on it
you know i mean that's at the bank
counter
to the goddamn curb
we'll talk right
just always
try to go with your first voice that's
your god talking to you whomever your
god is and that's changed over the years
of who my god is
right i went to private school i went to
parochial school
and so
i know the word i know the bible
i know concept
but [ __ ] it wasn't until being out and
about
that i really was able to meet who he
was because i'm his child
right
and so that was that
all the things that i thought it was
about turned out to be not what it
really was about in my thinking in my
heart and my core
right
and so yeah if you could have lived your
life differently how would you what
would you have done differently oh honey
child hush
how would i have done it differently
god leon 54 so every goddamn minute of
it would have been done differently
right
so that's a lot of tape
[Laughter]
okay so you guys can find me at janine
malone
dot com okay gmail i mean
yeah because i know i'm gonna be viral i
i know i'm just not goddamn good one
more question what would you say is the
most important thing you've learned in
your the most important thing you've
learned is that every person is on their
own
journey
and not to really try to have
expectations even though as a
a human
being encased in this flesh
we respond from our flesh and our
humanness
right
and so just to allow people to be whom
they are
right in conjunction with who you are
it's not that they're trying to get you
all the time it's just that your journey
and their journey is in conflict and
it's okay
after that part is over to go to
whomever and just be like you all right
now
right because if they're mad at you then
they're at you it doesn't necessarily
mean that you're mad at them
right
and if you need to talk to them go
holler at them get mad at you you're not
mad at them
right and i mean i tell my homegirls all
the time out here in the trenches that's
my family right so guess what [ __ ]
you're mad at me i gotta talk to you
[ __ ] because you don't know what i can
talk to about this so whatever
but i got to say it to your face and so
just listen then you don't have to
respond if you're mad at me that bad
[Laughter]
just know i'm not mad at you like you
mad at me and i got to talk to you and
so thank you for listening you know and
going about my way that's it
you know
just be able to know
that it's just all okay
you know it because everything is
conceptually on the circle
right the womb the world the sun
everything that we live off of is a
circle
and
so when things are hard
they're really not hard that's the good
[ __ ] but guess what it's just gonna
continually to rotate so the good is
going to go away and the bath's going to
come and the kid's going to go away and
the bat's going to come and at the
moment that you feel like you just can't
take your last step to say father
whomever you are
and i bet you
he'll come and help you take that next
one
and that's it you know
and it's all okay
promise you
all right janina thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you for letting
me share my story very interesting
thank you you're welcome
phew you're fun
you